There were a total of ten visits. Let's count them. We removed the last
element, we had to read the element for that purpose, but there was no gap to
be closed up, because that was the last one. Now before we can insert it at the
beginning, we have to move these four elements out of the way. Each of those
moves involves reading the element and writing it back to the next position.
That's two visits per element and there were four elements to be moved. And
finally the removed element has to be written back to the location zero. That's
one more visit for a total of ten visits. The point that I want to make is that
insertion into an array list. Doesn't work by magic. Under the hood, the other
elements do get moved out of the way. Now you've seen quite a few algorithms
for arrays and array lists, and many times you can solve your problems by just
using one of those existing algorithms. But there are also situations where you
need to understand the algorithm so that you can adapt them to new situations.
Sarah's going to give you an example where you have to do just that.